con la pausa del vídeo e intenta
averiguar cuánto es 27 + 1 y si es
posible averigua también cuánto es 27
más 10 muy bien ahora vamos a pensar
juntos en esto por aquí tenemos 27 más 1
y esto seguramente es muy fácil de
averiguar aunque hay por qué 27 más 1 es
el siguiente número más grande si
empezamos con 27 el siguiente número más
grande es 28 y tal vez está muy sencillo
pero la razón por la que estamos
haciendo este ejercicio es para pensar
en los valores posicionales por aquí en
el 27 tenemos un 2 en la posición de las
decenas decenas
y tenemos un 7 en la posición de las
unidades
así es que podemos pensar en el número
27 como dos decenas y siete unidades que
hay por aquí tenemos dos decenas aquí
tenemos dos grupos de diez unidades y
otras siete unidades y aquí están
nuestras siete unidades y entonces sí le
sumo uno si le agregó una unidad más con
que nos vamos a quedar pues voy a seguir
teniendo dos decenas estos dos grupos de
diez pero ahora cuántas unidades vamos a
tener pues vamos a tener uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho unidades
entonces va a ser 28 y bueno esto tal
vez nos sorprenda mucho pero está muy
bien que pensemos en esta suma usando
valores posicional es porque va a ser
muy útil más adelante cuando aprendas
más matemáticas bueno y ahora vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo pero ahora
con 27 más 10 como habíamos visto por
aquí 27 son dos decenas y siete unidades
pero ahora estamos sumando diez y aquí
el uno está en el lugar de las decenas
aunque hay por aquí el uno estaba en
las unidades y por eso teníamos una
unidad pero ahora el 1 está en el lugar
de las decenas
entonces tenemos una escena por aquí y 0
unidades el número 10 es simplemente un
grupo de 10 unidades así es que cuando
sumas estos dos cuánto nos va a quedar
pues ahora vamos a tener 123 decenas
tres decenas
y vamos a seguir teniendo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
unidades
así es que ponemos un 7 en el lugar de
las unidades observa qué pasó aquí
cuando sumamos 1 aumentamos el lugar de
las unidades por uno que haya 28 pero
aquí cuando sumamos 10 que 10 es
literalmente una decena aumentamos el
lugar de las decenas 1 y el lugar de las
unidades se quedó tal cual